eu estudei o curso de farmácia
logo no início da década de 90 e sempre
muito curiosa envolvida com um monte de
coisa muito de atividade
fui me integrando a projetos diferentes
dentro e fora da minha área
e dentre um dos mais marcantes mais
interessantes foi uma participação de um
projeto interdisciplinar e de vivência
em propriedades pequenas rurais aqui do
interior do paraná
isso consiste basicamente e no período
das férias a gente passar parte das
férias vivendo com famílias de
produtores rurais e eu fui
e esse grupo é multidisciplinar se
dividia nessas vilas e cada um de nós
morávamos com uma família numa casa
enfim onde pudéssemos ficar alojados e a
mim coube uma casa uma família que já
tinham a um grupo numeroso não me cabia
então eu fiquei alojada na escola que
ficava no terreno daquela propriedade
uma escola rural pequena e uma escola
rural que como era férias de verão
servia mais na verdade como um depósito
para secar feijão e eles empilhava as
vagens de feijão e eu abrir um espaço no
meio dessas vagens colocar o colchão
para dormir por ali e no meio de
barulhos de ratos em poder abrir a
janela pediu os insetos gigantes eu
passava as noites até que uma noite eu
acordei com um barulho de batida na
porta e insistente eu acordei meio tonta
ouvindo algo sobre alguém doente e eu
pensei assim meu pai e agora que eu vou
fazer eu estou no segundo ano do curso
eu nem só de remédio e alguém doente
eles querem que eu resolvo então vou que
eu vou fazer
ele levantei fui abrir a porta quando
abrir a porta eu me deparei com duas
pessoas que tinham nas mãos um livro
estender o livro pra mim falar assim
olha tem alguém doente e nós sabemos o
que fazer ea gente precisa que você leia
aqui o nome da planta para que a gente
vai procurar e preparar o remédio pra
fazer essa pessoa lê o nome da planta
isso eu podia fazer
ali naquele momento a perceber que por
menos que eu soubesse aquele meu
conhecimento poderia ajudar alguém
por menos que eu soubesse eu poderia
ajudar outros a ler um pouco do mundo
mas como como fazer isso
pensei entende que provavelmente a minha
vocação seria ajudá los a colocar os
óculos óculos estes do conhecimento
científico que eu estava aprendendo a
usar a universidade e assim passei boa
parte do tav da universitária envolvida
com a divulgação do conhecimento
científico
falando um pouco mais para mais gente
sobre essa ciência ajudando os a
encontrar um pouco outro ponto de vista
e uma das minhas maiores descobertas
nesse período foi além do conhecimento
foi encontrar descobrir a figura do
outro
me vi tendo a necessidade de mediar o
conhecimento com esse outro outro pra
mim foi e é e são os meus alunos que
cotidianamente me ajudam a me reinventar
a me redescobrir a construir junto deles
este conhecimento outro também os
orientados aqueles que a gente tem
oportunidade de viver mais perto e
vivendo mais perto eu consigo isso
mullah los e eu tento fazer com que lhes
desperta em para um respeito do sujeito
do paciente tu seu aluno como alguém que
é completo que é apto que é competente
que precisa de estímulos precisa que
alguém ajude a encontrar os melhores
óculos mas o mais importante que eu
descobrir foi na realidade um outro
maior que todos o que eu quero chamar
aqui de todos os outros
eu percebi que eu podia contribuir não
só com aquele que estava directamente
próximo de mim mas que todos mereciam e
necessitavam compreender melhor o mundo
que os óculos da ciência poderia ajudar
todos a ter uma compreensão melhor do
cotidiano das escolhas da convivência e
assim passaram se os anos e rapidamente
o tempo passa né ea gente eu me tornei
professora universitária muito jovem
muito cedo com 22 anos e nessa época tem
uma outra história que me marcou muito e
eu preciso compartilhar com vocês
foi um começo de ano estava ali os o
recém chegada à universidade e eu estava
ali encontrei um grupo de calouros
passando pela universidade e os calouros
calouro é um uma figura estranha né eles
andam em bandos eles se agrupam é calor
aquele cara que chega na universidade
ainda num não está muito bem informado
enfim e passou aquele bando e de repente
se deslocou um se destacou um veio pra
mim falou assim eu conheço você chega a
débora
eu quero te dizer que eu estou aqui por
causa de você
eu olhei pra aquele menino para aquele
rapaz pense assim
quem é essa pessoa que nem idéia de quem
é essa pessoa rapidamente
e continua a história eu vim para aqui
para a universidade há uns quatro anos
atrás
naquela época estava ainda no ensino
fundamental e quando eu vim com a minha
escola visitar aqui a universidade para
conhecer quem me recebeu quem atendeu
foi você e você mostrou um pouco da vida
da universidade mostrou ciência esta
ciência e eu entendi que era isso que eu
queria para a minha vida
conhecer mais integrar e aqui estou eu
por causa de você
naquele momento eu percebi que por menos
que eu fizesse eu poderia contribuir
para inspirar alguém me inspirar alguém
a querer usar os óculos do conhecimento
inspirar alguém é querer tomar a ciência
como uma forma diferente de ver o mundo
inspirar
quando a gente pensa um pouco a quem eu
posso expirar a quem cabe usar este
estes óculos a todos todos literalmente
se eu posso aprender todos podem
aprender eu digo isso porque eu tive uma
carreira que no mínimo era improvável
vem de uma família pequena de uma cidade
pequena vocês ouviram boa parte dos meus
tios meus avós viveram e morreram sem
nenhuma educação formal mas mesmo assim
na minha vida acadêmica eu tive
oportunidades
então todos podem aprender não importa a
idade não importa o local não importa o
estilo os óculos da ciência podem ser
coloridos podem ser mutáveis podem ser
adequados a climas e ambientes a
estruturas diferentes
quando eu penso em como fazer com que
isso chegue às pessoas
eu fui testando formas diferentes
escritas faladas viagens mostras eventos
e percebendo o quanto isso é possível
talvez você se pergunte mas
que nem todo mundo usar porque nem todo
mundo usa estes óculos da ciência
eu imagino que alguns acham que não
precisam
alguns não se sentem mil pçs mesmo que
passa em boa parte da vida tateando ali
o mundo
alguns não se sente pertencentes a
alguns não acham que merecem o que
conseguem alguns nunca conheceram porque
ninguém lhes mostrou quando penso na
universidade na academia eu começo a
encontrar pessoas que têm grandes óculos
da ciência que fazem com que eles tenham
uma visão tão específica que chega a ser
um olhar microscópico dedicou se a
grandes e importantes projetos
dedicam-se um olhar microscópico a
problemas que nem sempre são aplicados
porém muitos destes na academia não
perceberam a necessidade de partilhar os
óculos de repartir os óculos estão ali
focados alguns e goes estas outros
deslumbrados alguns ali envolvidos com a
sua rotina e dessa forma deixam de
extrapolar e mostrar para a comunidade o
quanto isso é importante
existem estudos que são feitos dito que
nós chamamos de percepção pública da
ciência
estes estudos aqui no brasil o último
que foi feito foi publicado em 2015
procurou identificar junto à população
algo como se comportam como acreditam
como imaginam a ciência na sua vida
existem muitas perguntas que podem ser
feitos muitos dados que podem ser
trabalhados e eu quero mostrar aqui
falar pra vocês três informações deste
estudo a primeira
o que foi perguntado para as pessoas
ocupam o quanto se interessavam pelo
tema ciência e tecnologia
e olha só 35% estão interessados e 26%
estão muito interessados em estudar 66%
de brasileiros que querem saber de
ciência e tecnologia
mas quando vai para a pergunta seguinte
para as próximas questões quantos
procuram saber mais sobre isso
quantos fizeram entender um pouco mais
da ciência
aí 40% não fazer nada e ao perguntar mas
fontes não confiáveis para obter o
conhecimento científico
as respostas são variadas mas apenas 7,8
por cento da população brasileira
menciona os cientistas é nós estamos
indo mal aquele conhecimento que nós
produzimos não está chegando pra
comunidade
só para você ter uma idéia do excesso de
foco que existe ou das mais variadas
idéias da pesquisa existe um prêmio
muito conhecido chamado ignobel e este
prêmio ele evidencia pesquisas que são
diferentes que são estranhas e uma das
pesquisas que chamou muita atenção em
2014 porque recebeu um desses prêmios
foi uma pesquisa tinha um problema um
tanto quanto diferente tinha como
questão a seguinte qual será o
comportamento das renas quando se
deparou com seres humanos vestidos de
ursos polares uma loucura não é uma
loucura mas é possível
nós mudamos isso é possível
o povo parece do conhecimento científico
para sermos cidadãos melhores pra sermos
pessoas mais críticas consumidores
conscientes para podermos contribuir com
as mudanças na nossa vida e na vida do
outro é preciso que a gente compreenda a
ciência amplie os nossos olhares
extrapola a nossa visão e isso pode ser
feito de formas diferentes
não precisa ser enfadonho não precisa
ser chato não precisa ser disciplinar
isso pode ser feito de forma criativa de
forma interativa
nós podemos promover a divulgação do
conhecimento científico de diferentes
maneiras
quando a gente começa a pensar quais são
os óculos que nós podemos oferecer para
os demais
eu refleti sobre isso e comecei a
perceber na minha vida
a participação tão necessária de pessoas
que me ajudaram a usar esses óculos da
ciência
existirão pessoas professores familiares
orientadores que dedicaram seu tempo
pessoas que dedicaram além do seu tempo
normal esforço que me ajudaram a
construir diferentes óculos não só da
ciência mas para viver a vida de uma
forma diferente
óculos que me possibilitaram a me
integrar melhor uma sociedade
e aí eu entendo que talvez essa seja
minha missão contribuir com a formação
de novos divulgadores da ciência
contribuir com a formação de novos
colocadores de óculos científicos novos
colocadores de óculos da ciência
o óculos pra vida talvez
dentre os meus desafios nesses últimos
20 anos esteja principalmente aproximar
a elite intelectual da universidade
especialmente mestres doutores e pós
doutores com a comunidade ao seu redor
mostrando que é possível partilhar o
conhecimento mostrando que é possível
tornar esse conhecimento informal porém
sério numa perspectiva adequada ao
interesse de cada um
e aí reside a minha missão e é isso que
me move é ajudar na formação e na
multiplicação de pessoas que possam
contribuir com a colocação dos óculos
talvez você esteja pensando assim mas o
que eu tenho a ver com isso né porque eu
nem cientistas o não gosto não quero não
faz parte do meu universo mas eu tenho
certeza que todos vocês que estão aqui
têm algum conhecimento que pode ser útil
para o outro
algum conhecimento que se for
compartilhado pode ajudá lo a entender
melhor a si mesmo e ao mundo que os
cerca a ver de forma crítica a perceber
os perigos e as armadilhas e aí eu te
pergunto qual é o óculos que você pode
compartilhar com os outros
pense nisso obrigada